two more house democrats announcing they
will not run for re-election bringing
the total number to 28. so what does
this mean for republicans looking to
take back control of the lower chamber
fox news contributor and former
congressman sean duffy joins us live
can't think of a better person to ask
this question to than you being a former
congressman you know we do talk a lot
about these retirements sean how big of
a deal is this that this number keeps on
ticking up now it's to 28.
well it's meaningful carly but first
let's take a step back why is it
happening right now for democrats why
are they leaving well a year ago
democrat party affiliation had a nine
point lead over republicans today
republicans have a five-point lead over
democrats that's a 14-point swing so
democrats today look and say this is
going to be a bloodbath a red tsunami is
going to crash upon our shores and i'm
going to make a decision not to run and
there's two groups in these numbers no
the first group is you know democrats
who are in hard seats or moderate seats
they think they're going to lose so
we're going to make a career change
right now before they actually lose that
race but the second group are democrats
from safe seats and they realize they're
going to be in the minority and what's
happened is democrats have been so
abusive to the to the minority to
republicans over the last four years
have had no respect for them i think
these democrats in safe seats understand
that when they're in the minority it's
going to be absolutely horrible because
republicans are going to treat them the
same way democrats have been treating
republicans for the last you know three
years so again they're like i don't want
to be in the minority i'm going to leave
and find another career path as well
yeah there are some republicans who have
lost committee assignments and now
republicans are saying if we take back
the house we're going to do that to
democrats as well president biden is
going to have
his first press conference in months
today
after
a lot of legislative failures crime is
still on the rise is there anything that
he could do to spin what's going on in
this country in his favor
that's a great question you can't spin
this carly this is um i mean it's bad
for people you can't you know tell
people a story and make them believe it
when their eyes tell them something else
what joe biden has to do is actually
change course right i mean you have to
stop borrowing and spending stop with
the big spending packages so we can
hopefully reduce inflation on the
inflation front encourage american
energy expansion and growth so we can
reduce prices energy touches all of us
at the gas pump for you know for heating
our homes but also it moves every single
product in in good across the country if
he did those two things um i think that
would go a long way to making people
feel better better about the future and
better policy coming from the white
house he has to do what bill clinton did
once bill clinton lost in the midterm
elections in his first term he pivoted
and worked with newt gingrich and
republicans and they were very
successful and he won a second term if
joe biden stays on this radical course
he's i mean he's going to continue to
lose and his party is going to get
absolutely wiped out in in the midterm
elections in november you know and sean
one of the issues that's really hurting
democrats is education and that letter
that the national school board
association sent to the department of
justice and president biden comparing
parents to domestic terrorists and now
senate republicans have written a letter
to education secretary miguel cardona
saying that letter was the proximate
cause of attorney general garland
issuing a memorandum directing the fbi
and the various u.s attorneys to focus
on harassment intimidation and threats
of violence directed at school officials
that action has created a dramatic
chilling effect on parents and is an
inappropriate deployment of federal law
enforcement they want more answers on
this front will they get them
oh well so first off the the department
of justice needed a pretense to to go
after parents um who were just
protesting uh policies in schools they
didn't like they weren't violent and so
they used the department of education to
solicit this letter from the school
board association to start this whole
you know fbi process going after parents
so i think we're going i mean listen i
think we're going to get some answers
but not until the senate and the house
change are we going to get real answers
when republicans have gavels and can put
about the possibility of the house
republicans regaining the house in in
the midterm elections sean thank you so
much for joining us i went to brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now